Senator Josh Hawley represents Missouri
he joins us tonight senator thanks so
much for coming on why do you think that
health authorities in the west and of
course are mindless media uncritically
accept Chinese health statistics and use
them as a basis for decision making here
well you know tucker these these same
people I mean the Washington elites the
Wall Street types and the media
establishment have all pushed closer
ties with China for decades they're the
same people who've been telling us that
this will be great for America and the
world if we integrate our economy with
China's it'll be great if we have a
global economy where we send jobs
overseas it won't really matter as it
turns out they were wrong about all of
that they've been wrong about this whole
bargain it's been terrible for America
and now we're living with the results so
I think this is we're finally waking up
to or at least the DC elite are finally
waking up to the wages of the bargain
that they've struck and it's time that
we fundamentally rethink our
relationship with China and the world
it's time to start putting American
workers at the front and not Cal telling
any longer to the Chinese government
we see this epidemic primarily in
epidemiological terms our screens are
crowded with people in lab coats reading
stats and giving in some cases good
advice I'm not attacking them I'm not
sure China sees it that way how do you
think China sees this moment what are
the stakes in their view well they
clearly see it as a geostrategic
opportunity the same way they see
everything I mean listen they have a
plan they want to be these central power
they want to be the dominant world power
they have a saying that there can only
be one Sun in the sky that's the saying
of Chinese government officials and they
intend that son to be China to be
Beijing and they see this as an
opportunity along the way but here's the
thing tucker this is also an opportunity
for us it is an opportunity for us to
open our eyes the American people have
known this for decades they've known
that partnering with China is dangerous
they've known that sending our supply
chains overseas was wrong now we have
the opportunity to correct those
mistakes it's time that we go all-in on
America rather than all-in on China and
we're gonna have the chance to do that
now I hope so I mean we can start by
ceasing the subsidizing of the
education for the children of Chinese
leads I know this is off topic but I
can't resist our colleges universities
almost every one of which is supported
by taxpayers in the end educate at a net
loss the children of the people who are
trying to displace us why are we doing
that yeah and we also allow those
educational institutions to take money
directly almost from the Chinese
government these Confucius Institutes is
they're sometimes called tucker that are
on campuses all across the country
directly subsidized by beijing you might
ask why do American campuses allow these
Chinese government outposts on their own
campuses and the reason is they get paid
to I mean it's it's actually lucrative
so yes we have got to stop this cozy
dealing with Beijing on our campuses
with our international trade from our
financial institutions and I'll and our
multinational corporations it's time to
actually put the American worker and
American families and American interests
first it's time to put them at the front
and that's why I say we're gonna have an
opportunity now and we need to not miss
it to invest in this country to go
all-in on this country and I hope that
that will be our focus this pandemic
should make clear to us that it is an
urgent urgent need that we do this going
forward I think you're exactly right
thank you for your clarity and I and I
marvel that there are people working
against those goals which are so clearly
positive and overdue senator great to
see you thank you thank you